dans les villes le couvert végétal ou ce
qu'on appelle aussi l' indice de canopée
devrait idéalement atteindre 40%
mais dans les faits les arbres ne couvre
par exemple que 20% du territoire à
montréal et 32% à québec
et selon les quartiers riches ou moins
riches c'est un indice de canopée peut
varier grandement ce qui fait dire à
certains chercheurs qu'il est temps de
s'attaquer à ce type de justice
environnementale
[Musique]
mais
et
quartier montcalm à québec ici espaces
verts et arbres matures côtoient
habitations et trafic urbain
aux balkans à l'angle qu'on semble l'été
s'amorce que les chaudes journées mais
des gens notre petit mathis naturel est
arrivé depuis c'est l'apôtre de la
justice environnementale
un concept de plus en plus connue qui
allie justice et écologie selon ce
principe chaque citoyen devrait avoir
accès à un environnement de qualité
cet hyperactif en a fait la quête de sa
vie comme chercheurs mais aussi comme
artiste militant et membre du groupe les
cowboys fringants
je pense que c'est un appel dans du
moins dans mon coeur un appel à
l'engagement pour essayer de donner
cette nature à tout le monde
les feuillus en été pour bien comprendre
son propos nous avons parcouru quelques
quartiers de québec
en commençant par la haute ville cette
cohabitation de la nature et des
activités humaines qui est vraiment bien
intégré on peut voir avec large des
armes que c'est un quartier on a pris
soin de nos arbres pour jérôme dupras
les arbres sont des fournisseurs de
services on se promène un petit peu on
peut remarquer que des feuillus des
conifères différentes essences
donc on est dans un quartier riche de sa
verdure une richesse qui selon lui
devrait être beaucoup mieux répartie
historiquement bas on n'a pas fait
beaucoup de place à la nature dans nos
quartiers et lorsqu'on s'approche des
quartiers qui sont plus densément
peuplées ou qui sont plus urbanisées
c'est là qu'on voit progressivement
disparaître l'arbre dans le quartier
saint sauveur en basse ville de québec
la végétation se fait plus rare sauf
pour les parcs où l'on trouve quelques
arbres plus imposant il faut aussi
habiller nos quartiers de vannes
on est dans le camp du rocher c'est un
très très beau parc des armatures mais
si on veut aussi un hymne quartier on va
se rendre compte que les immeubles sont
collés aux trottoirs n'y a pas d'arbres
de rue pour nous offrir un plus c'est
impact visuel mais aussi tout l'ensemble
des bénéfices qu'on peut comparer en
résulter
geron du bras est conscient des
contraintes dans la gestion de la forêt
urbaine
mais cela n'empêche pas de mener sa
bataille pour corriger ce qu'elle
considère comme des injustices
pourquoi on est dans un quartier pauvre
montréal pour le dixième mois
d'espérance de vie que dans un quartier
favorisé évidemment ailleurs les
indicateurs socio économique classique
entre le revenu l'accès à l'éducation la
taille du ménage venues ont essayé
d'ajouter à cela des variables
environnementales
la nature et la proximité sa nature là
c'est aussi un marqueur très très fort
des inégalités sociales
pourtant une étude de l'institut
national de la recherche scientifique
réalisée il ya quelques années à
montréal n'a pas démontré de problème
majeur des kits et environnemental une
comparaison entre les quartiers pauvres
et la moyenne générale a révélé un écart
d'à peine 3% dans la couverture végétale
jérôme dupras lui préfère comparer les
réalités des deux extrémités de l'île de
montréal
quand même des disparités incroyable si
on regarde les deux pointe de l'île de
montréal
donc l'extrémité est on à
l'arrondissement montréalais l'est et à
l'ouest senneville et d'un côté dans
l'est on a une église de canopée qui est
à cinq points 8 % alors qu'il est à 60
de l'autre côté
dans l'est le revenu moyen par ménage
est d'environ cinquante huit mille
dollars pour 204 mille de l'autre côté
avec son équipe de l'institut des
sciences de la forêt tempérée
le chercheur analyser la qualité des
arbres dans des villes comme québec
montréal et gatineau
ce qu'on trouve c'est assez frappant c
fera pas parce que dans des quartiers où
on a plus de
de même monoparentales de plus de
personnes par logis plus faibles revenus
on peut faire un lien avec non seulement
la quantité de verdure mais aussi leur
qualité plus quand je dis qualité c'est
leur résilience face aux changements
climatiques aux espèces de ravageurs à
la sécheresse
ce jean colas a fait est exceptionnel
par sa taille fernande 940 à 128
sentiment de diamant les arbres anthony
daniels les étudie depuis 20 ans c'est
un filtrage et inclut maintenant un
arbre rafraîchir voir non seulement par
l'ons qui va produire mais également par
la droite par loulou qui va émettre dans
leurs feuilles il a développé une grande
expertise dans la contribution
écosystémique des arbres et suit avec
grand intérêt les travaux de jérôme
dupras enfin vous savez les seules
infrastructures urbaines qui prend de la
valeur avec le temps plein dans mes gros
pire feuillage plein va ralentir avant
les arbres seraient donc indispensable
en milieu urbain mais encore faut-il
planté le bon arbre au bon endroit en
prenant soin de bien varier les espèces
lorsqu'on se retrouve dans des quartiers
qui sont plus défavorisés la forêt elle
est moins diversifiée donc moins
diversifiée moins capable de s'adapter à
plusieurs types de pressions sur sa
dépression climatique des blessures des
espèces invasives ici dans le quartier
mile end à montréal les autres bétonné
avoisine les secteurs plus riches en
verdure
m différents des portraits des forêts
urbaines des exemples sur les aînés
critiques sont assez parlants
un arme individuelle on peut dire en
quelques kilos de courbes usure et
rapidement ces disparités
jérôme dupras a développé avec d'autres
chercheurs l'explorateur de canopée
urbaine une application qui permet de
connaître et de chiffrer les services
rendus par les arbres des différents
quartiers de montréal
combien de kg de carbone séquestré à
chaque année combien de mètres cubes
d'eau son réseau racinaire bottines
absorber combien de grammes de polluants
atmosphériques ça va ça va ça vos
captures et donc l'idée c'est d'essayer
de démocratiser cette lecture sur la
forêt urbaine de vulgariser et de
développer comme sa nouvelle forme
d'attachement envers notre espace vert
la ville a même utilisé ces données pour
concevoir des étiquettes comme celle ci
une opération qui vise à faire connaître
la contribution souvent sous-estimé des
arbres on a dit pluie de plus en plus
importante avec les changements
climatiques et c'est plus avons causé
momentanément des inondations dans
certains secteurs donc on n'a pas eu le
choix de bâtir mais bassem rétention les
compléter des millions de dollars à
construire les ans vont agir comme un
tampon qui vont ralentir ses débits
pointe le donc ralentir l'eau de
ruissellement se planter des arbres pour
corriger une forme d'injustice a
toutefois un prix des villes comme
montréal et québec
le font depuis quelques années elles ont
d'abord cibler des zones plus
problématique qui font des victimes lors
de grandes canicules donc 800 chaleur
des travaux d'envergure qui sont très
coûteux soir élevé on parle de file du
béton de retirer de la salle de creuser
défonce pour permettre la plantation de
nouveaux arbres dans ce secteur mais la
stratégie principale c2d bétonné des
endroits pour créer les nouveaux espaces
et avoir des milieux
harb qui vont permettre justement un
meilleur apport écosystémiques par la
banque est aussi un apport arboricole en
général jérôme picard et conseiller en
environnement québec
l'ingénieur forestier partage cette
vision de justice environnementale mais
doit tenir compte des conditions de
croissance plus difficile des arbres en
particulier dans les quartiers densément
peuplés construire la maison slater est
son plus petit donc l'arbre devient dans
le tout autre considération qu'on a à
faire sur un terrain
sur un trottoir par exemple leur durée
de vie dépasse rarement 10 ans on
l'oubli mais il faut d'abord que l'arbre
survie pour en tirer les bénéfices
mon art doit se déployer correctement
[Musique]
à québec la revitalisation des berges de
la rivière saint charles
autrefois d'étonner est considéré comme
un des modèles de réussite pour redonner
aux résidents un environnement de
qualité
cette logique des trames vertes c'est
une idée de ne pas mettre la nature sous
cloche de verre mais de bien la
distribuer de miel à connecter sur le
territoire pour permettre à tout un
chacun d'eux de circuler à l'intérieur
de leur ville
mais au final est ce que cette notion de
justice environnementale est vraiment
applicable
donc le droit l'environnement il est
reconnu déjà dans des textes de loi
lorsqu'on essaie de les acquérir dans
des décisions juridiques politiques
c'est très difficile
la quantité d'arbres qu'on devrait avoir
dans une forêt la couverture idéale
on parle de 40% dans une région comme
l'anneau le fantastique réalisation
géraud du produit rêve du jour où la
forêt urbaine sera considéré comme un
billet collectif a partagé de façon
équitable
que ce soit par l'art par la science par
l'activiste un grand devoir d'humilité
qu'on n'a pas rapport devant la nature
[Musique]